no lb drivers are we're a special breed
you have to be a little aggressive dude
have to be a good distance we bike a lot
downtown
there's Metro City right oh yeah yeah
yeah and you know it we play like fight
to the gym it's such a movie theater I
had white back from the drinking future
concert my boyfriend was like and it was
waiting for the road I had a daughter
and then my daughter said hey you know
what I'm going to Metro bike and just
driving on Skid Row
I've had a heart attack oh honey can I
hide my friends actually like at night
like once a month past in Skid Row just
for like a reality check
they enjoy it they may be kind of
appreciate like what they have that's a
little bit you know what is very good
but it's kind of [ __ ] up at the same
time today I don't look at home with
people to good perspective do you see my
like oh I'm twice your size up ten times
more scared than hello one time I like
I have to calm down and sometimes forget
the like right there you're getting a
little you know I'll give it of course
because that you're like oh they're
going to come up I'm just like I wish
you good
I was composing in my head like the
things that are not even just like in
Skid Row but if someone tries like mess
with you like I do everything like just
where the guy just walked it up in like
like 10 o'clock with me like I think of
like the traumatizing things I would do
to him and like the first thing I would
go for like you know people like super
meanie - so I was like Gophers eyeballs
or something like you know it's like it
was picking my balls the coach azar say
yes you're like oh what somebody would
when I Drive down here oh I have that
doors online I bet I didn't happen right
the night and I open the door he was
right never mind
crazy crazy and I you look like Mary all
continue laughing them so I like you
I generally had sex with women who I
thought that emotional connection with
so I think that generally has like never
happened I tried to stay off from having
sex before marriage specifically for
religious reasons so when are you was it
no thinking microscopy Oh was it
romantic or an awkward because we're a
girl losing it is so not sexy it hurts
it hurts you're confused you don't know
what you're doing at all and now there's
a foreign object inside your body so
you're being strong right when I first
had sex it was like hallelujah but
pretty sure for her she was like she was
like there's a foreign object in my body
I'd like it hurt by even after two out
there like did it hurt you yet for
better final [ __ ] yeah I'm sorry that
acaba yeah the figures it's like so
awkward for women and that's why so guys
they're just like peak sexual age is
like eighteen and it goes down low from
that but women are paid sexual age is
like around 30 and I suspect aside from
like asides aside from like the hormonal
biological whatever stuff that has to do
with the fact that what dude it's like
literally all you have to do is stick it
in you're like oh this feels good yeah
let's do more though with women when you
swear start it's soft and hurt you don't
always do it and then as you continue
practicing the checkable board you get
better you get to know yourself and so
by the time you're 30 I think you
finally figured out where the g-spot is
how does make it good for you even if
the guy doesn't know what he's doing you
maneuver it and all the stuff so that if
the guy doesn't know what he's doing I
think it's up to the woman to let the
guys
because that's the problem guys are
[ __ ] talking for no reason
there is like oh dude Vic is so good if
I speak didn't she go like you know what
you know
no you have to maneuver it correctly
well of course yeah it looks like you
somebody grabbed my penis and then you
stroked it it's gonna feel good but
there has meat to it that makes it way
better
oh if a girl if the person that you're
in a relationship with doesn't correct
you and then you're leaving unsatisfied
that's your fault because you never told
them okay the guy is thinking that his
dick is really good question though when
the appropriate time to do that because
you want to do it during snacks or
you're like oh well we're doing it all
around anyone ruins the mood okay first
of all when you're [ __ ] you want to
be like turn on the lights
oh honey let's talk about this one you
know we don't do that no you just kind
of talk to them while you do it to make
it right now you're doing it yeah you
just tell them like like sex [ __ ] tom
is a belated Oh like make it fun and
exciting you don't just [ __ ] stop it
no I'm doing that because I don't know
how to not awkwardly do it and while
you're doing your life I am RapidArc
what I'm gonna stop doing what's done or
you wait after and midnight and you do
this do that
and the guy's not gonna be like let him
do that no he's gonna try you gotta
[ __ ] come alone
but you have to if there's not at that
point if you are not being said like I
said for a guy as long as somebody
stroking is it they're pretty much like
bear for a girl because there's a lot of
techniques and all the cities are
certain spot that you should hit and
every girl spots just a little bit
different really so at that point not
the g-spot is still the same but some
girls like it differently than other
girls so at that point it's all about
communication right that's interesting
so it's like constructive criticism but
done in sexy talk mind blown thank you
maybe there should be tries maybe later
on they should bring it up but it should
be relatively early cuz you don't want
to have bad dick constantly no no no
nothing worse than bad dick you know so
it's just communication people don't
communicate very well I'm not saying I'm
the Guru of sex but I will think that
will fix my problem admit it you have an
issue it's like oh I don't like that
come on I'll do it what do you prefer
that it's being told during the moment
or after when you're like oh honey it
could be either more I don't have any
feelings on that type of stuff I think
getting close can you have sex with one
woman for the rest of your life
I'd like to naturally and be okay with
that or do you think at some point you
I've heard I will say who described this
as like well it's like flavors of ice
cream you don't want to just go to know
about both of these flavors that's just
up to the individual but you think human
beings are actually biologically
you have other not facility I don't know
about that but we do for me I can't
because my life is driven by sex
we have hires not that you still has
been having our sexual organ dictate
what we like or want in life that is
something that is unfortunate but it's
not one of those things where I have to
think about well I want a different foot
I want a good one you know what I mean
like what do men prefer that like in the
house I can't wait
I don't speak for that but I know
because I like sex I like sex but
emotional having an emotional attachment
to put somebody in there that much
better
yeah so it's different for the admission
to vidual some people just want to stick
their dick and everything just yet
some girls just want to dig inside of
the desert
[Music]